dr david wearing joins me now and there
are a lot of people in newcastle who
will be very happy to see the back of
mike ashley um they will say that they
are just going to hold their nose uh and
cope with the the new owners what is
your view on that
well that's their choice i guess but
let's be quite clear about why this is
happening
um the saudi regime is not buying
newcastle united because they're great
lovers of football and it's certainly
not because they've got a great concern
for the people of newcastle and their
enjoyment of newcastle united's fortunes
they're doing it for two main reasons
the first is what's called sports
watching washing which is using which is
authoritarian regimes using sports to
whitewash their public image around the
world we've seen that in lots of
instances we've seen it with the chinese
in the 2008 olympics we've seen the
russians and the uh
world cup a few years ago we see it with
the regime in qatar which owns paris
saint-germain we see it with the uae and
abu dhabi's ownership of manchester city
and now we're seeing saudi arabia
newcastle united the purchase of a
football club to whitewash the image of
an authoritarian regime
and in the second
the second reason why they've bought the
club
because there's going to be investment
in the club but also the investment in
the wider community as well
one of the ways in which these
authoritarian regimes particularly in
the gulf and in the middle east
bind themselves to the big powers of the
global north especially the us france
and britain is by investing in these
economies
and by doing that they're able to prove
their worth and their value to the
british state and in return for that
they'll expect support from the british
state in local and geopolitical
issues like for example the war in yemen
where the saudis have been which assad
has been waging for five six years now
with a lot of british assistance there's
a geopolitical aspect and there's a pr
aspect as well
um saudi's crime prince mohammed
mohamed bin salman has made much of his
uh efforts to reform the kingdom it is
improving isn't it but
how much
yeah i mean let's be honest it's not
really um
and this is something that my research
has focused on a lot in the last couple
of years
the the language of reform is really
part of the pr spirit we have to be
quite clear about this so i'll give you
one example at the same time as the
saudis were telling us that they're
reforming and using the example of the
fact that they are now allowing women to
drive cars
they locked up the women's rights
activists who had campaigned for the
right to drive and those women were
subject to according to the leading
human rights organisations absolutely
horrific treatment while jailed for
while jailed for campaigning for their
basic rights
and decided that saudi arabia is
reforming in the sense of its politics
and sense of political freedoms and
civil wars is is just not true i'm
afraid what they are doing is reforming
their economy and then reforming their
economy
to give a more sustainable basis for the
saudi world family to remain in power
and by the way while we're talking about
the human rights record of the saudi
regime it's not just a question of how
the saudi regime treats its own subjects
in terms of the jailing and
alleged torture of women's rights
activists and many other dissidents
peaceful distance it's also about the
saudis behaviour in yemen where again
they're credibly accused by all the
world's leading human rights
organizations of indiscriminate killing
of civilians even if the potential use
of starvation as a war tactic which is a
war crime
and so this is a kind of regime that's
now about to it seems purchased
newcastle united a regime of a horrific
human rights record and a record um of
behaviour in war in yemen which mainly
which may go all the way up to
guilt of potential war crimes and it's
this kind of behaviour that they're
trying to whitewash with their purchase
of newcastle united that's the purpose
of the purchase
i mean it has been widely reported as
you're saying all of these things and
amis international um themselves have
have lobbied the premier league to try
to stop uh this sale going through do
you do you think that the premier league
will listen to this or do you think they
will just allow it anyway it sounds like
they won't and
from what i understand that the test of
the premier league applies to potential
uh purchases of football clubs there's
no real um human rights test
um and then in fact amnesty had been
lobbying the premier league to adopt
such a test so you can't just have any
old person buying a football club
um i mean look
we wouldn't accept the dictatorship in
syria by newcastle united we all know
what the dictatorship in syria is guilty
of um and amnesty is saying that there
needs to be a specific test to block
these sorts of people
from from exploiting british sport and
exploiting these clubs for their own for
their own ends
um it looks like the premier league are
going to wave it through and one of the
reasons apparently from reading the
reports this morning and last night that
the premier league are going to wave it
through
is that they've been persuaded of the
argument that's been made
that the public investment fund the
saudi sovereign wealth fund which is
going to be the major shareholder in
newcastle united going forward they've
been persuaded by the argument that the
public investment fund
is not is a separate entity an
autonomous entity from the saudi regime
i'm afraid
this is just nonsense it's laughable and
any expert on the saudi regime on the
political economy of saudi arabia will
tell you that
the sovereign wealth fund is
is a tool of the regime its chairman is
mohammed bin salman the guy who's been
accused of the body americans of of
being complicit in the murder of jamal
khashoggi of ordering the murder of
jamal khashoggi um he's the chairman of
the public investment fund which
apparently is going to be the major
shareholder in newcastle united and that
sovereign wealth fund is really the
center of his entire economic strategy
over the last five or six years the idea
that is separate from the regime is just
a nonsense but the premier league
apparently are going to argue that it is
separate and that's how they get
this whole deal through and past their
fit and proper person tax
okay dr david wearing we'll leave it
there interesting to talk to you today
thank you very much